hey Marv big fast boy big fast quit
think fast barking move way big fast
what fast way think fast
way big fast way hey Mark the fast way
hmm you really need to work on your
reaction time maybe you drive a winner
in this bill hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to reaction time
the video where I embarrass myself in
front of the whole internet and gaming
community to show how piss-poor my
reactions really are says the guy who's
twerked in a thong before what am i oh I
get it obvious oh well then go me go um
maybe I won't be so bad
wait a minute wait that was it wait a
minute no no no no no no no wait there's
got to be more to it than that
wailing is that it that's it that's
literally the whole game it's the same
thing over and over I just have to put
my god I got to beat my high score every
time who is gonna be good I'm amazing oh
my god oh oh oh it's over oh it's really
hard that's it that's it upgrade I can
do upgrade I can do the upgrade thing
alright alright come on come on whoa
whoa whoa oh I forgot that there was
more time
let's bump up the gold multiply all that
was not last I was gonna go into two
times but I guess I was too easy not to
be mistaken with two cars my brother's
webcomic of Extraordinary imagine it's
over so quickly and I die climactically
and that's not a euphemism jail Energon
drunk not fast enough
and so embarrassing but so soothing
at least the soundtrack is bumpin so
that I don't have to be distracted when
I'm failing all over the inner but I do
better now why do they gotta be so Paik
oh no I can go fast
no one saw anything there no I'm sorry
ah to my memory I could do this well it
would help them find us looked at the
screen instead of you lovely people out
there as much as you're handsome and or
beautiful okay I mean this is kind of
fun for how simplistic it is if I didn't
suck ass the trick is to not look at the
shapes but I look at the hole I just
realized this whole time that you
probably couldn't see my mouth so I
turned it on so that you can follow
along and see how amazing I really am oh
[ __ ] in actuality I'm very [ __ ] in
actuality and very talented like it
stopped talking and focus on what I'm
doing okay okay hi bunch update it all
over the place
however if I artificially increase the
speed if you guys can notice why if I
tell you guys about it you guys would
respect me more probably wow I'm going
to pass you can't believe that I'm
talented yet anybody who's anybody
please
oh this game is addicting it hard just
like dicks
alright challenge everyone out there to
do better to do good at an iPad game cuz
it's happy touch and then the little
babies would be able to do it better
than me maybe someday I'll go to the
shape clipping a little clip click link
click okay maybe someday I'll go to the
shape clicking Olympics in there I'll
make my home country proud and what I
can do with my fingers why do I want to
succeed so badly why am I here to prove
myself against you guys I think my life
is gonna be filled with ray god no oh oh
I salute the exit button Oh
so anyway if you want to play a game
that leads to happiness in long life
you'll just start running around [ __ ]
whale babies the face click on the link
in the description below sauce [ __ ] you
have a fun time it'll be great you won't
waste your life playing it so thanks
again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
this holy
and that is